just suis charli or I am charlie
millions of tweets and Counting around
the world used this hashtag to mourn the
shocking killings in Paris France On
January 7 gunmen stormed the office of
satirical magazine Charlie Hebdo
reportedly opening fire on an editorial
meeting and saying the Prophet Muhammad
had been avenged at least 12 people were
killed in a surreal scene that spilled
over into the streets of central Paris
as three suspects fled just sweet
Charlie Charlie Hebdo Newsom Charlie and
other hashtags quickly spread on Twitter
Google friends featured a black ribbon
and red it's robot logo carry there's a
sweet Charlie sign the magazine's
homepage itself looked like this as
Parisians gathered that night to mourn
ever durably ma said 12 dead 66 million
wounded referring to all of France
online and at solidarity vigils people
paid homage to Charlie Hebdo legacy as a
source of irreverent and provocative
cartoons
there was a weeping Charlie Brown and
this tweet saying you kill one
cartoonist you create two in another
image the pencil turns on its would-be
attacker pencils and pens came up again
and again as symbols of free expression
and defiance but you better believe
Charlie Hebdo has its critics in 2011
the magazine published a caricature of
the Prophet Muhammad on its cover that
led to its office getting fire bombed a
year later the magazine published more
drawings of the Prophet keep in mind
such depictions are a big no-no too many
Muslims that magazine being racist and
horrible doesn't make the attack okay
similarly the attack doesn't make their
horrible racist magazine okay
hashtag Genesis we thr Lee I am NOT
Charlie has also been used by tens of
thousands Genesis we fought Charlie
because charlie Abdo was a racist
publication and I opposed both terrorism
and Islamic obeah many have feared and
already tense climate for Muslims and
France will only get worse in the day
after the shootings there have been
reports of at least three attacks on
mosques around the country one love make
sure to pray for the Muslims in France
shits about to get real and they don't
deserve it we should point out that
Charlie Hebdo is known as an equal
opportunity offender lampooning everyone
from French politicians to the Pope the
magazine takes what many have called a
principled stand not just for
free speech but against self-censorship
faced with this event the only response
is to continue to laugh at everything
and everyone
hashtag Charlie Hebdo in fact the
magazine has vowed to keep publishing so
what do you think are you Charlie and
what does the hashtag mean to you